based on what I've seen as expected you
guys zero for that the calculations easy
to you're pretty much just yeah I just
want to point out there's one little
thing you might not have noticed if for
example you get a question like this and
you don't get asked the circumference
you get told the circumference and then
you have to work out say what's the
radius okay now because if you're doing
the radius you can work out the
circumference you couldn't go in the
opposite direction as well alright so in
case you've already encountered this
questions how would you set this out
like you can obviously go to calculator
did you get a number out of it but what
would you write to communicate like I
know what I'm doing before you reach for
the calculator what could you do very
good I would usually start off as you
know I said this by say 2 PI R that's
that's where I'm gonna put my numbers in
but ours the thing I'm trying to work
out ok so if the circumference is 2 PI R
and if I wanted I own up I'd use the
other form all I need to do to get R by
itself is what do I do I'm solving this
equation fully enjoy both sides yeah I'm
gonna divide through both sides yeah so
divide this by 2 pi and divide this by 2
pi
does that make sense yeah the inky thing
about this you can't sort of cancel but
as you know you can play with your
calculator pi is a messy number right so
you're gonna get something a bit worse
out of this you're going to get articles
can someone actually punch it 15 divided
by 2 pi for me too how many does give me
a five six two point three eight seven
three two eight seven three two yeah
yeah yeah at this point usually the
question will say can you give me a
certain number of decimal places and
that's fine however based on what we
looked at everyone even if the question
didn't say that you could work out how
far to approximate it right
are you going how far have I going to
approximate on something like this think
about it think about it that 15
centimeters that was measured right I've
written that's 15 centimeters but it
might not be 15 seventies
what's the range of the accuracy of that
what do you think I've given it to you
in [ __ ] centimeters so what you could
assume is that the limit of reading or
whatever I use to measure seen yards is
a centimeter right so that means this
really could be like fourteen point five
or fifteen point five yeah so that's the
error that I'm going to introduce but
that error comes along for the ride when
I work out the raise right so what do
you think I should round this off to
yeah well what I'm saying is for example
suppose it was fifteen point four nine
right then on my measuring instrument I
would have rounded it down to fifteen so
yes you're correct okay it looks like
I'm going to the deers toughest enemy oh
right that's the real accuracy that I
have so I would do the same here so like
I said the questions you're actually
going to encounter in the exercise they
probably gonna say two decimal places
does she do me the figure something like
that but without it if you were actually
measuring this out and you wanted to
know I think it would make sense to say
to enough okay because that retains the
same level of accuracy that you started
with it was just kind of implied here
does that make sense okay anyway that
was just as an aside because you're
sometimes you get the question reversed
for you let's have a look at these three
examples which will take you into five
be crazy but it's just a little this is
a setup so the sectors that either we
give to when you've got a circle and you
divide out some part that meets a
percent of the circle
okay so if this were a whole circle if
you had this correctly
what would you do to work out the
circumference
well the promotion said yeah if it were
included yeah what would I do what would
I write down I'd say yeah divided by
four okay so if I want to try get this
part that's just a quarter of the circle
right so that's just a quarter of that
the whole circumference if I wanted the
whole circumference it would just be to
play off right so two times pi times
three that's the radius right now
remember Chris just said that's a
quarter yeah so the part that I want is
the rest of it with it which is what one
quarter but three quarters so I'm gonna
go to three quarters of the
circumference and that will give me this
round pot is curved bit around the edge
okay that's really good that's the first
thing to settle I've only got part of
this femoris so three quarters of it
that's all yeah but there are bits that
I'm busy
right what do I add to that to get holy
okay so there's an edge here that's
three and there's another issue that's
three so the entire perimeter is this
plus two months of three and that'll
give me the actual number I would can
someone tell me what that is
here my monkey got a calculator started
what to do yeah 20 points how many give
me two okay so not that complicated
well you have a look at other shapes
sometimes the pieces that you want that
but it curves further around then they
separate it out so if you have a look at
this just walk through the dimensions of
a running track all right when you look
at the bits you've got this round pot
over here in this round pot over here
but despite the fact that they're
separate if you combine them then all
you would get is just that would you get
you just get a circle right so you can
consider those pieces and then add all
the straight agents yeah so you hear
what I say perimeter equals now I could
use two pi up that'd be fine
but look at this semi meters that I've
gone how does that relate to the circle
the dimensional it's the diameter so
instead of using two PI R I'm going to
just use PI types whatever that diameter
is which in this case is seven eight
okay that takes care of the curved parts
then what are we added to that to get
the entire page you lost 100 she lost
behind is it I'm not even gonna worry
about what the numbers cause I'm
confident you guys know what to do we
calculate this from there okay last one
you'll start to get to shapes where they
combine things eat Weaver's so this is a
semi circle attached to a semi circle so
let's dig events carefully oh I've got
actually a few different plots that I'm
going to think through so I'm going to
number them just so I can keep track of
them
I'll call that big curved part the first
link I'll call this radius and second
leg and then I've got a smaller city
several years
let's go through the one by one I'm
actually going to use rooms what's the
first company okay so so this city so
good right remember how we have 3/4 of
the circumference over there here I'm
gonna have half of a circumference so
I'm gonna go 1/2 times and I have the
radius so I'm gonna use the reason 2 pi
which is just yeah so you can see this
case in fact have you written this out
before I got flow calculator the half
attitude thank you
so this is 8 times pi which is like 25
26 someone's gonna give me that number
I'll just write down a private down and
you can the second plot is just a so I'm
what are you gonna do anything for that
let's do this last one this is a city
circle again but it has a different
radius from the big one that's what
makes this almost any central so how
would you let me to work out okay so
it's gonna be it's a semicircle right so
I've got me half of something right and
the half of something I've got the diam
so you've got choices right again you
can use the same two PI R that we just
used
oh that ain't right it's the diameter of
the little circle yeah so I can just use
I can just use this form right pi times
the diameter so I'm gonna go 1/2 times
pi times 4 PI because half a day is
sport
so now if I completely I could say
therefore they're proven our position
right that is equal to you've got a
dozen movies but I do it a play what's
the big city circle 8
was that little straightedge there and
then foreplay was the small season event
out you'll evaluate you of a witty
calculator okay so what do we take from
all of these number one just be
carefully about the different pieces
you've got so you've got a pair part
straight parts make sure they're all
accounted for here and secondly if you
ever encounter a question like this and
they sometimes get a little more finicky
okay if there's lots and lots of pieces
give them labels and that way you won't
be city and you systematically we done
forgotten about all the way through